I hate makes me anxious I don't like
touching people and I don't like
touching things ever since I was little
I hated it I've learned to pretend like
I don't know what a hug is if you stay
out of arms reach I can't get you I see
somebody I know and I'll smile from afar
and then hide it'd be nice if I could
come out of this and be less anxious
about having them touch other people
this is a problem of mine I should
probably fix it I'm sure that'll change
once I continue to go to therapy but as
of right now I just like to be alone you
know some people just don't like each
other's smells if people thought I
needed a hug people gave me like a
really good hug every person was so
excited to have I think people like hugs
and they told me I was a good hugger
those nice does he like sort of an
outpouring of like support of people
being like oh yeah I'll hug you
he's just hormones just too much I hug
my best friend who I've known for 12
years
that was sweet right foot blue
now we're twisting this is my nightmare
people love this game that's pretty
lucky
[Music]
that's making great progress I would
like to not hate it so much I wanted it
to quit the beginning if I were to
practice my social skills a little
better I'd be a lot more willing to hug
my I hope after this I can like I'm like
a husband kind of guy maybe one day
[Music]